pour contrôler plus souvent les
personnes de couleur non blanches parce
que inconsciemment bain ce sont des
dangers donc la baule et c'est raciste
pour 20 la question c'est pas savoir si
la police est raciste
c'est pourquoi la police se comporte
différemment avec certaines personnes la
police représente l'état et l'état doit
garantir l'égal de l'égalité entre
toutes les personnes et peu importe leur
couleur de peau
est ce que vous comprenez la colère des
policiers après des propos de lilian
thuram nicolas pernikoff ja comprends
c'est totalement scandaleux alors je
sais qu'il avait parlé de cette
expérience dans un restaurant ou des
noirs avait été refusé puis était passé
derrière la personne avait reconnu
immédiatement mais vous rentrez je sais
que c'est une histoire à l'épaule srx
est un malade il est resté marqué par sa
fille d'amis c'est bien sûr mais bien
sûr c'est inadmissible a été par contre
on peut pas dire que c'est culturel
parce que ça voudrait dire que les
français sont racistes donc il faut pas
généraliser et de l'autre côté dire ça
de la police mais ça ne fait
qu'enflammer une fois de plus ce qui se
passe en ce moment avec la police qui
essayent de nous aider de nous sauver
qui a quand même un rôle extrêmement
important pour tout le monde alors il ya
eu d'autres extraits mais on va on va
reparler c'est la bouffe dit non oui je
trouve qu'il a le droit de dire ça c'est
lilian thuram c'est par un politique
c'est son ressenti à l'huile il a appuyé
sa avec des anecdotes personnelles et
encore une fois y avait cette anecdote
du restaurant où les taxis ont refusé de
le prendre
donc effectivement la petite phrase qui
était sorti lé choc mais lui il a le
droit de donner son insu alors on veut
pas le bâillonner évidemment il a le
droit de dire tout ce qui veut dire
le problème c'est en fait pour moi ils
confondent de combat il a un combat qui
me semble qu'il est très très juste
c'est celui de la discrimination de la
stigmatisation est effectivement moi je
trouve qu'il ya évidemment une
discrimination à l'embauché une
discrimination parfois à l'école pour le
logement il ya plein de problèmes dans
la société française mais malgré tout
moi je trouve que son problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils racialise ce
débat c'est à dire qu'en fait il ne met
pas les gens semble aimer les blancs
d'un côté les noirs de l'autre et en
fait c'est ça c'est ça son problème en
fait ils essentialiser à la race et dit
ce sont les blancs sont les méchants
l'homme blanc et méchant l'homme blanc
est par nature raciste et pour moi c'est
ça le problème avec une lentille ram
c'est qu'en fait il ne règne pas il
il ne sait pas j'avais dans l'idée la
police comme si c'était la police
entièrement composé d'éléments blanc
compte contre tous les autres médias de
plus en plus de mixité dans la police et
c'est très bien
sur donc dire comme ça à faire un espèce
de tout global c'est injuste répond non
il a raison sur les propos comme a dit
géraldine il faut se battre
ces trucs de discrimination il faut se
battre sur le fait parfois tu croises
des gens et le gaz août c'est un arabe
ou dc d'immigration où les noirs ou les
chinois et les indiens aux étoiles
étrangers non il est français c'est pas
parce qu'il est noir qui n'est pas
français
il est même plus français que toi si ça
se trouve donc là dessus il faut se
battre sur sa part ça change
après son cas quand il dit les vénérer
les flics arrêtent là que dès que les
noirs c'est pas vrai parce qu'en
province les flics ils font quoi alors
ils arrêtent personne puisque avec des
blancs en province et dans les campagnes
on parle de citer dans les cités où il
ya beaucoup de mixité dans les camps il
ya les logements sociaux il ya beaucoup
de mixité et quand il dit pareil sur ses
enfants moi j'ai appris à mes enfants
avec la police en cas de problème c'est
pas ben il restait alors est très calme
justement et d'arbres un livre il a
parlé de son fils n'y a pas de problème
avec la police en allemand il a parlé de
son fils parce que thuram qui avait
craché au visage d'un de ses adversaires
lors d'un match du championnat allemand
il avait écopé de cinq matches de
suspension et d'une amende de 40000
euros je crois regardez ce qu'ils en
pensent du crash à ton fils bien sûr
qu'elles sont extrêmement choquant de
ces images là et c'est très
irrespectueux pour pour l'adversaire
c'est très irrespectueux pour lui même
et surtout si très irrespectueux pour sa
grand mère voilà et donc je pense que
les personnes qu'il aime beaucoup ont pu
lui dire à quel point nous étions déçus
moi je le rejoins c'est mon héros de
france 3 c'est lilian thuram je rejoins
quotidie la police machin il arrête que
les noirs ils arrêtent tout le monde la
police tu reste tranquille au contrôle
d'identité
tu donnes tes papiers ça se passera bien
y'a pas besoin de nous enflammer à
matinée avec michel par exemple sur ces
réseaux géraldine c'est qu'il ya aussi
des pourris dans la police on l'a déjà
dit oui en fait j'aime pas quand on
parle de vérité à géométrie variable
quand qui scande son fils il a craché
sur son adversaire pendant un match en
or en allemagne
il a été le premier à dire non non il
n'a pas craché la postillonner il a
commencé à travestir la vérité et après
après qu'on lui ait montré images il a
dit si finalement il a craché bon c'est
pas bien bah ouais mais faut faire
attention
alors on va voir avant c'était un
spectateur s'il vous plaît oui à 50 % à
50 % c'est incroyable c'est vrai je vous
livre son accès 50/50 crois que c'est
une des premières armes que ça et c'est
incroyable que vous soyez aussi voilà
partagés sur les fractures et malgré
tout quand c'est avec mes passions il ya
c'est vrai ça ça prend beaucoup de
solution d'un problème